Peter,
Jay Peterson.
Originally,
I was brought up in the middle of
Nebraska in a small rural town,
1,733 miles to Boston and 1733 to sam
go.
Um,
very profoundly.
My parents were Greek immigrants.
They came here without a pen,
a without a word of English and a third
grade education.
And they moved out to men,
Nebraska because that's where their
relatives,
where my father took a job.
No one else would take washing dishes
and the caboose of a Union Pacific
railroad that was being built.
It was steaming hot there,
which I guess the reason no one wanted
to take the job and he ate on the
caboose and slept on the caboose and
saved a virtually everything he made,
which he turned into the inevitable
Greek restaurant 24 hours a day,
seven days a week for 25 years.
That never closed.
And he was there all too many of those
hours,
weeks and uh,
and years.
I didn't say I'm a great as much as I'd
like because he'd leave by six in the
morning and he'd come home about nine
o'clock at night,
pretty much exhausted.
So my brother and myself could spend a
few minutes with him then usually,
uh,
providing some hot water and salt for
his legs that were swollen with varicose
veins.
But he was a great model of,
uh,
working,
achieving,
and saving for the future.
He believed deeply in America.
He believed deeply in the American dream
and we seem to have forgotten as the
American dream is all about your,
your children doing better than you do.
And one of the reasons he saved was
that,
uh,
he wanted,
as he put it
to bias,
the best education money could buy.
And indeed he did.
So I learned a great deal from him about
focusing on the future,
focusing on your goals,
uh,
saving
and investing.
My mother was also a Greek immigrant.
She spent most of her time cooking and
making all the clothes we wore,
which at times got pretty embarrassing.
She did everything.
She washed iron scrubbed,
mowed the lawn.
Uh,
if there's anything she didn't do around
the house,
I don't know that during World War Two,
when they build an air force base near
the small town,
the business exploded in size and she
worked many,
many hours there too.
But for much of her life,
she was the typical American homemaker
I'd say.
And we saw infinitely more her than we
did.
You know,
him.
The first born son,
psychologically,
as we all know,
has certain advantages and certain
problems.
Um,
in my case,
I was treated like a prince and I,
uh,
had the great advantage during the first
three years or so of,
uh,
probably they're developing a pretty
healthy sense of self esteem and
affection.
We ran into a tragedy.
However,
when I was four,
my one year old sister died suddenly
from croup form of pneumonia,
I guess.
And she was my mother's
attempt to be born again,
you might say through her daughter
because he's great wives,
live very tough lives giving how their
husbands were working and when she lost
her beloved daughter,
she went into very deep mourning.
And I,
uh,
as a child who normally
thinks we,
I think we think of ourselves as the
center of the solar system.
Everything revolves around us.
We're responsible for everything.
I guess I wondered why as my mother
withdrew and to the deepest,
deepest depression psychologically what
I did to cause her to abandon me,
added to my complexities,
I guess you'd say.
I formed a,
uh,
a pattern of having to achieve and
having to be perfect so I could somehow
regain her,
uh,
her affection and her intention and
that's had some good points and just had
some bad points because trying to
achieve perfection can be a productive,
that can also be a very destructive
process after a while.
So she had quite an impact on me
while I was pretty dumb about
recognizing whatever talents I do have.
George Ball,
the grade under secretary of state,
and one of my partners at Lehman used to
refer to me as relentlessly analytical.
I'm pretty good at analyzing problems,
getting the facts,
raising the right questions and uh,
and so forth.
I'm also a peculiar combination
of a total mechanical Klutz in the sense
that I'm incapable of operating in the
most simple machine or fixing it.
But I've always been rather creative on
asking questions that is inventing the
questions.
So I went through some job changes early
on,
which reflected a certain,
almost invincible ignorance of my
qualities.
I did my graduate work at University of
Chicago on Adam Smith taught us about
comparative advantage and how you ought
to focus on your comparative advantage.
So for reasons that aren't clear at all
to me,
I went into retailing
yeah.
And uh,
was assistant manager of a toy
department at Christmas,
if you can believe that.
And
if,
if that experience played to my
comparative advantage,
I can't imagine what they were.
So I quickly got out of that business
and got into the market research and
analysis business was where I belonged.
And later on into the advertising
business where I could combine whatever
analytical ability I had
with working with a creative people,
by asking them questions and suggesting
problems that need to be solved without
knowing how to sell them.
So I think my talents are somewhere
along the line of analyzing things and
having a certain sense maybe of where
the world is going and being reasonably
creative and asking the questions that
sometimes lead to creative answers.
Well,
I'm a huge believer in dumb luck.
I think Donald Look beats a smart
planning much more often than we would
like to admit.
Uh,
people have,
uh,
incorrectly praised my quite varied
career,
including government service and public
service.
And I like to explain and how I got into
going to Washington and President
Nixon's White House and later to his
cabinet,
I was working at 39 self of cell in
Chicago.
MMM.
I used to walk to the railroad stations
a lot cheaper.
And um,
I one day I noticed at 19 south of cell
there was universe Chicago graduate
school.
Well,
I been planning to go to northwestern
where I'd done my undergraduate work,
but it was all the way across Chicago
and since it was night school,
it would have taken me 20,
30 minutes to get over there in 20,
30 minutes to get back.
So I said,
well,
you know,
maybe I had to go to the University of
Chicago.
It's supposed to be a pretty good place.
So that's why I went to the universe.
Chicago.
It has nothing to do with career
planning or anything of the sort.
It was there that I made some of the
best friends I have on the faculty.
Uh,
Milton Friedman,
George Stiegler,
George Shultz,
and George later you'll recall,
became a very senior figure in the Nixon
administration.
He became secretary of Labor,
uh,
office of Management and Budget
Secretary to Treasury.
And then later in the Reagan
administration,
Secretary of State and George and I had
worked very close together,
University of Chicago.
And I had taught there for about four or
five years,
part time at night.
Okay.
So one day he called me and said that
President Nixon wants to see it
tomorrow.
So I go to Washington.
I ended up in the Oval Office and uh,
the president pointed out to me that,
uh,
he thought economics was going to become
terribly important at the vortex and
foreign policy and that,
uh,
yeah,
he and Henry Kissinger,
my good friend had a very complicated
relationship.
For some reason he felt need to tell me
that Henry didn't know a damn thing
about economics and uh,
what was worse?
He didn't know what he didn't know.
So he went on to set up a new council
counterpart of the National Security
Council and I was to head it,
well,
this isn't a anything I had planned or
anything and I've looked back on that.
I've been immensely grateful for my
public service opportunity,
some of the most exciting experiences
broadening I'd ever had.
It has led to my being involved with
some great nonprofit organizations.
I just stepped down after 22 years as
chairman of the council on Foreign
Relations.
I'm the founding chairman of the so
called Peterson Institute for
International Economics,
one of the founders of the concord
coalition.
And I doubt very much I would have done
those things if I hadn't gone to
Washington.
And I thought I'd go into Washington if
I hadn't have,
didn't happen to have an office at 39 as
long as southwest cell in Chicago didn't
happen to have a downtown school at 19
southwest cell.
So never,
never
underestimate
the role of luck in life.
And I think the trick,
I've forgotten who the councilman was
and uh,
in New York who once said,
I seen my opportunities and I took them.
Um,
I think it's important when you do have
something that luck thrust upon you to
somehow be made in such a way
psychologically.
That is Paul Tillich said once,
if you're comfortable with ambiguity,
that's,
that's what you need when you're in a
rapidly changing world.
So I say dumb luck and taken advantage
of your opportunities will often lead to
more instinct places then a longterm
smart career planning.
Sure.
I do a lot of traveling around the world
and I,
and government,
I got to know other governments as well.
That's a remarkable country with regard
to its absence of barriers.
Uh,
is resilience.
It's responsiveness.
Just think of it.
Uh,
when my father started his restaurant in
the 1920s,
the restaurant was petitioned by the Ku
Klux Klan saying,
don't eat with the Greek.
There were no blacks there.
So I guess they figured the grapes where
the next most desirable,
um,
target.
We go from a situation like that
to where if anybody's been prejudiced
against me because I was a great guy,
been unaware of it.
MMM.
I worked in the 1960s with,
uh,
when I was CEO of a company called Bell
and Howell with Martin Luther King.
And I went through the tragic
division and racism of the,
of the 60s where blacks were formerly
and most often informally blocked from
all kinds of participation in American
life,
business,
social,
political.
I looked today to Barack Obama and,
uh,
okay,
I think it's quite possible today,
let a black could be elected president,
the United States.
And that's taken place in a remarkably
short period of time.
So this is a country with limitless
frontiers and very few barriers.
And if you work hard and study hard and
you've got good luck,
you can do very well in this country.